alright let us assemble the council and
let's talk about a specific moment
perhaps one of the greatest moments in
geekdom in film history in fact I would
go so far hi holy crap you don't have to
be Star Wars fan you don't even have to
have seen the movie everybody knows that
and its iconic and it's amazing but it
shouldn't work why shouldn't it work
what the heck is he talking about well
first let's accept the fact that George
Lucas did not invent that twist it was a
very old very cheesy twist in fact the
idea that the villain is in some way
related to the hero usually in the form
of father or brother here's the thing
though traditionally when that sort of
relationship is revealed it can't be
revealed by the villain because the
villain has no credibility we have
absolutely no reason to believe him in
fact we have every reason to doubt him
he's the bad guy why are we gonna take
his word
normally that sort of information would
be sparse doubt by the obi-wan Kenobi
character the character with knowledge
the character with integrity the mentor
type character those are the ones who
traditionally would reveal to the hero
the person who you are fighting is your
brother is your father is your cousin
twice removed whatever the heck it
happens to be it has to be them we have
we need to believe them because if you
question the reveal then the reveal has
no power so that's why those sorts of
characters need to be the ones to say it
but he wasn't one of Senator Darth Vader
said it so why do we believe it James
Earl Jones he's gone on record as saying
that the first time he read that in the
script his immediate reaction was that's
not true he's not really his father he's
telling a lie that was what he thought
so why don't we think it I think it
comes down to one key aspect and it's
not the words
it's not the voice it's not Luke's
reaction I think what ultimately that
moment hinges on and what makes us
believe it is the thing that happens
between when the words I am your father
are spoken and just before Luke has his
meltdown we get this those notes that
music John Williams managed to take the
Imperial March theme that had already
been established and give us that slight
similarity to that classic dun dun dun
which is stupid and cheesy but always
makes the point Oh Donna it has that
feel to it but there's also a melancholy
to it there's a loss of innocence to it
because Luke just lost the citizens the
audience just lost their innocence and
that music is why we don't question it
that's what sells it that is why we
believe in that moment if you take the
music out there would be I would guess
about half the audience going I don't
know if I believe you put that music in
there everybody believes it you got one
of the most iconic moments in film
history and on that note this council is
adjourned